in the last 13 years the longest you
stayed in one place was ten days suppose
sometimes I get myself into a bit of
mischief I saw the number that data is a
trillion dollar your industry multi
trillion when does Facebook come into
place what country should you really be
living in who's your favorite Disney
Princess this has given you information
not only your data but the data of
everybody else in your network how does
that make it legal though it's not
anybody you can buy that data bought
farms fake accounts troll factories
they're going to show them those
pictures of a polar bear standing on a
tiny piece of ice see all that fake news
I bet they're not gonna show the middle
finger she put up this is a crazy
political upset do you think Rachel
Maddow is gonna be on by never what does
that tell you huh Wow do we have a right
to opt out you've never had any right
sign me up it means that our democracy
is up to the highest bidder that's
called being dumb the more you find out
the worse it is did you ever think you
would make it take sweet victory I know
this slice meant for me why would you
bet on July it well we got red tape now
you came it gives it values today this
this world of entrepreneurs we can
evaluate this run homie look what I
become I'm under born
[Music]
so today's guest is Brittany Kaiser who
is Cambridge analytic --is whistle
blower also the author of targeted the
Cambridge analytical whistleblowers
insights story of how big data Trump and
Facebook broke democracy and how it can
happen again Brittany thanks for coming
out thank you so much for having me yes
so so you and I were talking earlier and
I was asking you you know what it's like
to have the life that you've had because
you've been all over the world and you
told me the longest you stayed in one
place was what the last 13 years for
only 10 days so let me get this through
so everybody understands it's in the
last 13 years you've only the longest
you stayed in one place was 10 days
sometimes I don't stray too far I'll
just go to a neighboring city you
somewhere else in the same state or the
same country but sometimes I'm in a
different country every day how much of
that is because of your personality how
much is of that is because of what
you're currently at a bit of both I've
always been someone that loves to
explore the world find out everything I
possibly can go and see and do
everything I can get access to and
sometimes that turns out very well and I
suppose sometimes I get myself into a
bit of mischief
who were you know who were you if I was
friends with you like what kind of a
ten-year-old kid were you not even in
high school I want to know how you were
at 10 years old when I was 10 years old
I spent a lot of my time sitting in the
corner of the playground reading the
biggest book I could find and not
joining in the games of tag the biggest
book you could find biggest book I could
find or I'd be at home working on my
history fair science fair project or
studying for mathletes or debate club
how though is it your wiring was it
inspired by pen because I know your dad
I think was like a real estate that he
was in real estate and mom was with
Enron before was there conversations
about politics was there conversations
about like deeper issues or was it just
more in your DNA my parents always
raised me to work as hard as I possibly
could and to be a very high achiever
they both grew up in households where
they had I would say they weren't
completely motivated to be
the most academic students they got
involved in a lot of things as kids
parents yeah so they just felt they just
felt that they wanted to give me
opportunities that they didn't have so
did they kind of flip meaning good they
didn't have the highest standard of
expectation and they said we're gonna
have a higher standard expectations'
from you
exactly it's interesting how that goes
because it's like oh it's too high I'm
gonna be a little bit more liberal
leaving my kids on this thing and kids
come back cuz I want me a little bit
more discipline well I wouldn't say a
little bit more discipline my mom was
raised military so she had a lot of
discipline but she was the oldest of six
kids raising them on a military base so
she was almost like a second mom and
didn't really get to concentrate on her
studies that's tough and you also when
you're when you're in that situation
sometimes you also are not able to be a
kid or a teenager because your so much
as relied on you to lead so you almost
skip a generation of your life and you
sometimes look back and say I don't even
know what it is to be a kid yeah my
mom's expressed exactly that very many
times what kind of conversation was it
if I'm in your house we got four or five
cameras at your you know dinner table
you six o'clock you know Thursday night
you're sitting having dinner you're 11
12 years old mom dad sitting what are
you guys talking about I would say
probably what I did in school that day I
was always very interested to talk about
what I had learned what I was going to
do with it
what I had done after school I was very
lucky to be put in you know art lessons
and photography lessons and be playing
sports after school my parents really
spent all of their lives trying to make
sure that me and my sister had as many
opportunities as possible and obviously
you did I mean to see what you ended up
doing yourself where you're at today
there was a lot of that grown up
absolutely was there conversations about
politics and different issues or not
really so interestingly enough my
parents have considered themselves
independent for a lot of their lives my
dad's side of the family although
they're from Chicago they've always
leaned conservative but they voted for
both Republicans and Democrats my mom's
side of the family are military
Republicans that grew up in all over the
world so they do
a world view but they've lived by a
military base and in the south for a
while and I've always voted a Republican
so my parents really didn't have a
strong you know party stance and they
never really instilled that in me or my
sister even when we were little they
wanted us to feel out what what our
religion should be what our political
views should be without enforcing that
on that kind of that kind of was left on
you which is great because it allows you
to think for yourself I grew up in a
family my mother's side they were
communists my dad said they were
imperialists so for me it was that girl
oh yeah was it was crazy you know yeah
it's like if MSNBC and Fox News got
married and had a baby that's me I'm the
baby of them and said you see a fox news
that's kind of amazing that's kind of
like it's kind of confusing because you
love these for these people and they
have such different worldviews but it
first makes you just now won't have
anything to do with it and then later on
a little bit of the itch comes back and
I'm just curious why my mom thought this
way mom my dad does this way that's why
I asked to see where you were at so
you're 14 years old I think you're 14
years old are you in Scotland where you
get this inspiration to go and want go
support Obama President Obama's campaign
that is that right is that really
happened so 14 was when I joined Howard
Dean's campaign his primary that was
2003 I suppose I think I was 15 or 16
when I first met Barack Obama that was
right after Howard Dean had lost the
primary to John Kerry and then I was
supporting John Kerry as a volunteer and
I go to the DNC the Democratic National
Convention in Boston in 2004 and the
young State Senator Barack Obama is what
you were there
absolutely yeah it was I was in at
boarding school and there was a summer
program that I was invited to
participate in called lead America and
they taught kids how to run political
campaigns so we did a mock political
campaign I actually ran for president
I had a campaign manager and the press
team and all of this different stuff it
was it was really interesting to learn
all of the mechanics like that while
you're at the deans
so they would take us to you know
different caucus meetings and different
rallies and I went to this very small
environmental rally there are about
thirty people there and State Senator
Barack Obama was the keynote speaker
with only 29 other people competing with
me for his time when he stepped off the
stage how was that the first time I saw
him speak
it was awe-inspiring actually I had
heard of him before but I didn't really
know much about him obviously state
senators don't get a lot of press or
fame but I'm from Chicago so you know I
knew of some of my point of view what
part of Chicago yeah Lincoln Park is
where I grew up and I was just so
excited about what he was talking about
supporting senator dick durbin in
blocking British Petroleum from dumping
into the streams and waterways that
would that were polluting Lake Michigan
and I thought that was something I
wanted to get involved with I thought
that I should support him in any way I
could and I asked how do I do that
he said volunteer for my campaign for a
US Senate I'm going to be running and
come to breakfast with me tomorrow
morning if you're from Illinois so I did
that and at breakfast the next morning
he said by the way I'm making a speech
tonight jan Schakowsky why don't you get
her a ticket I was sitting there having
breakfast with him me rahm emanuel i got
some yeah i'm 15 or 16 years old and i
get this ticket and i go to see his
famous speech about how we're not the
red states and the blue states were the
united states and that's when i knew
that he was going to be President it's
the moment you know some people have the
moment that was the moment where you
heard him speak you said this guy could
be a president now at the moment you're
sitting or having breakfast with them do
you have any idea who he is going to be
like are you getting a feeling of this
is a very special guy he could go places
did you know that all absolutely how did
you know that you can feel it from the
second that you meet I mean a lot of
people only have the opportunity to see
him through the TV screen which is
unfortunate because when when you meet
him he just has this aura about him
where you can tell that he is
genuine that he's powerful and that he
has trie intentions genuine powerful and
true intentions that's a good
combination yeah it is that's a good
combination to be a president one day
absolutely to term president one day
right exactly variant so from there what
happens so you do that you work with
them then what happens next so I went to
go finish high school I left the United
States when George Bush got his second
term that was my last year and it was my
first year going to Scotland so I
started college there at Edinburgh
University and it was in my second year
there when Barack announced that he was
going to be running for president or
senator Obama I should say I thought
well you know university is great and
all but it's not as important as this
guy becoming president of the United
States what you're thinking yeah so I
left University actually I told my
professors that if I was going to leave
I was doing something important I'm
gonna go work on the u.s. presidential
elections aren't you so excited for me
they said oh great you're going to work
for Hillary Clinton it's like no that no
Senator Barack Obama he's my senator and
from the state of Illinois and they
didn't know who he was so they said well
it's it's really not a good idea for you
to be leaving University in order to you
know just go go work for someone that's
not going to win they told you this yes
more than one professor they said you
know if you leave now that the best
grade you can get is you know a 60 or 70
percent because you'll be failing all
your exams I said okay fill me then I'm
leaving was it almost like a proving a
point thing to you or no like did you
get that ship saying what do you mean
this guy's not gonna win did you get
that feeling yourself or no I realized
that it was it was going to be something
that they looked back upon and regretted
not me
did you ever go back and see them or no
yeah I went back and finished my degree
of course so you had a conversation
after he got elected was that
conversation like
it was more like well congratulations
Adem you know and the first one was the
first one was McCain right McCain and
Palin you're doing your school and then
what happens next I was in school wall I
got the opportunity to go study abroad
in Hong Kong and I was very excited
about this this was actually why I
didn't apply for a job in the Obama
White House most of us that had worked
on the campaign were offered that
opportunity to continue and move to the
White House once we won and I said well
I've been studying Chinese for so many
years I got this amazing opportunity to
go study in Hong Kong I've never been
there it's really important for me to go
and explore Asia after studying Mandarin
for so long and Asian history and Asian
religion it's actually much more
important to me to go do that you
believe that that it was much more
important to you yes why is that going
out and seeing the world and
experiencing new things was always kind
of the core of what I wanted to achieve
in my life of see as much and explore as
much as I could in my lifetime but also
I really thought you know if I'm going
to come back and do the American
government any service it's probably
going to be more in a diplomatic role
ambassador me doing communications for
the White House is not a good use of my
time actually so I I did go to Hong Kong
and very quickly got wrapped up in the
human rights world there which is very
topical now of course but this was 2008
and my eleven years ago now all they
talk about yeah exactly
and in 2008 the Chinese government was
trying to push something called article
8 which would have given the Chinese
Communist Party a veto over anything
that was decided in the Hong Kong
Parliament mm-hmm and this obviously put
the people in Hong Kong in an uproar
because the entire point of them being a
special administrative region is
they are allowed to administrate their
own region they have their own
Parliament they make their own decisions
and I would spend a lot of time marching
in the streets it looks kind of similar
to the things that you've seen recently
the big protests you know out with
umbrellas so the cameras can't see your
face people wearing masks and protesting
and demanding that the Parliament get
rid of this or the Chinese Communist
Party to stop pushing that it's not as
it's not as bad as some of the bills
that they tried to put through this past
year which is why the protests now are a
lot worse but it definitely became a
core part of what I did while I was a
student there and I started really
getting into human rights and luckily
met some incredible people that did a
lot of work at the United Nations and at
the European Parliament and I thought
well you know I'm studying international
relations actually human rights is what
I want to do because the people that I'm
meeting here and working with every day
are very inspiring are you when you when
you're going through that with being
inspired to do work with human rights
the deeper you get is it getting more
troubling to you and is it more unsafe
to talk about it openly that we need to
do something about this that did you get
an end up feeling there or no the more
you find out the worse it is definitely
definitely in China specifically China
specifically has always been a place
that I've concentrated on in terms of my
research and my work originally because
I thought it was one of the greatest
civilizations on earth and I wanted to
go live in China and know everything
about it and then when I started
understanding the politics there and the
way that people are treated and the way
that minorities are targeted I thought
this is a place I don't want to be but
it's a place in need of reform and maybe
I can help that what made you believe
it's one of the greatest civilization
was it the education was at the school
and you went to was it a professor that
painted China to be a great place in
America's not as good as China was there
any influence there or was it yourself I
originally it was actually my
grandfather who spent 27 years and
military intelligence and originally
infiltrate in the infantry in Korea and
in Vietnam he was a paratrooper and then
went into military intelligence for a
long time and when I was in eighth grade
preparing to go to boarding school I
told him grams I want to take Japanese
I'm I'm given this amazing choice of all
these different languages and I want to
take something that most of my friends
are not going to get the opportunity to
take and you said no no that's not what
you want to take I see they also have
Chinese as a choice you should take
Chinese it's like okay or they explained
to me why he goes this is one of the
most powerful civilizations on earth and
by the time you are in the working world
probably at least a fifth or even a
quarter of the world is going to be
speaking this language and it's going to
be much more important than Japanese and
you need to know that now this was 2000
I suppose was he was he a my active at
the time or no was he military
intelligent was he selective or no are
you ever inactive what I'm saying
religion once you're 27 years was he
still during his 27 years was it post no
technically retired okay he would still
get calls when assistance was required
I mean 27 years of experience they're
going to be able to use the Intel and
experience you got so they're going to
call you that so it's very said so what
was your grandpa a big inspiration into
being who you are today
definitely he was so very close that's
your mom's dad yes yes make sense so
okay so now you're in China you kind of
see what's going on your the deeper you
get the more concerned you are what do
you do next so I had to go finish the
fourth year of my degree at Edinburgh
University this was my third year abroad
in Hong Kong so I came back to finish my
it was technically a master's with
honors in international relations and I
was doing international law and Chinese
as the two kind of other main components
besides just international relations and
so I came back and I ended up writing my
entire master's thesis on human rights
in China on Falun Gong persecution
the illegal organ harvesting trade on
persecution of weekers you know Muslim
minorities and the political prison
camps which is not just something I
learned in Hong Kong the people that I
met there gave me accreditation to go
participate as a human rights lobbyist
at the European Parliament and at the
United Nations in Geneva so I spend a
lot of time there with a lot of the
world's top experts a lot of people who
were considered defectors who had
escaped political prison camps or
re-education through labor camps they
call it and I was just kind of blown
away by some people's story is and the
gravity of the problem because it looked
very much like well you know I grew up
Jewish and going to a Jewish school and
it looked very much like a lot of the
stuff that I had studied about the
Holocaust growing up and I was shocked
to find out that there were things like
that still going on in the modern world
you know I'm still very young a teenager
and starting to figure all this out and
I thought well this is the topic the
world needs to know about what what do
what do people think about when you
compare that I mean I'm sure it's not
the first time you've said it had signs
of a Holocaust type of tendencies what
do people tell you when you shared that
with them this was I don't want to see a
taboo topic with still a very minority
group of researchers and human rights
activists that were involved in exposing
this type of these types of abuses back
then now it's a little bit more
mainstream more people understand it it
comes up a lot more in the press it
comes up a lot more in diplomatic
conversations when countries like the
United States are thinking about their
relationship with China and it's it's no
longer I would say a topic that you
would have to be in a tiny meeting room
in some far-flung wing of the European
part of the building to know about now
it's it's a lot bigger so I'm happy that
so many people have followed that
through and done something
put pressure but I definitely think
we're we're hopefully starting to live
in a world where things like that cannot
go unseen anymore what do you think I
want politicians protect China you don't
sometimes people are too careful like
even today like there's I'll have guests
that will come here and I'll interview
them and they'll say there's only one
thing I can't talk about what's that
China this is the one topic I can't talk
about China what is it with so many
politicians business folks you know any
word that has any kind of link to China
that's not the one topic you want to
talk about it's because they're afraid
afraid of what though afraid of Chinese
money being pulled out of their
businesses afraid of Chinese companies
not wanting to do business with them
afraid of Chinese spies following them
around trust me I've had that happen to
me Chinese spies follow me well
absolutely definitely especially at all
of the meetings at the you know European
Parliament in the UN where China is
discussed there's plenty of people there
where they're wearing badges that aren't
even their real name you don't know
where they came from they're not from a
human rights organization it's pretty
obvious but a lot of people are afraid
of that and I you know I totally
understand you know I I totally
understand but if you're not willing to
stand for something then you stand for
nothing
I agree with that and it it's in a way
empowering them to know that you're
afraid of them to me it's exactly what
they want they want to impose the fear
so you stop talking about it because
they'll threaten you in their own ways I
mean you got sports you got NBA being
hit by it you got businesspeople being
it buddy got politicians being a bite
yeah very interesting what's going on
right now with them so so how does whole
this whole thing come about let's go
right into Cambridge analytically that's
when you're experienced you've done a
lot of different things you worked on a
lot of different projects how was the
transition from where you're at to all
of a sudden saying I'm gonna work with
Alexander I'm gonna go and work with
Kimber Kimber general Etica how did that
happen right so I was still going back
and forth between my academic work and
my activism which was all you know pro
bono spending my student loan to get
myself to Geneva to the UN
and I'm in the third year of my PhD I'm
writing a doctorate on something called
preventive diplomacy which means that
the people in the world that holds the
most diplomatic power so heads of state
presidents prime ministers ambassadors
preventive diplomacy is how they can
intervene in situations before massive
atrocities happen so how do you stop war
before it happens how do you you know
intervene in a country's economy before
there's massive inflation or a famine
there's all of these different factors
and somehow my entire doctorate or at
least the third chapter that I was
working on when I met Alexander was all
about how you could use big data and
predictive algorithms in order to
predict the future and find out that any
of these atrocities or war or violence
or any other problems in society find
out that they're going to happen before
they do so that you can intervene early
on and prevent it now no one at my law
school could teach me about big data or
predictive algorithms so one of my
friends introduced me to the CEO
Alexander Nicks that's actually the
first chapter of my book and I thought
hey this is very interesting he was
using data for defense he was using data
for politics he's using data for
humanitarian purposes okay this is the
type of stuff that I need to learn if
I'm ever going to finish my PhD so let's
see if I can get a bit of consultancy
work and get an income besides my
student loan payments and see where this
goes
how was he pitching you when when you
first meet him how impressive of a guy
was yeah I know you talk about when you
met President Obama you know presence
character power all of that you know
combined together what was Alexander
Nyx's personality - for some you met him
I really thought that he was someone
that was guy doesn't describe him
as a you know very posh the the type of
Englishman that didn't usually describe
the friends that I had on a day-to-day
basis but someone that was so incredibly
privileged that he had extreme expertise
he knew about things in the world
because of his access to powerful people
because of probably tons of projects
that he had undertaken around the world
and he had power so it wasn't that kind
of inspiring Barack Obama feeling no
nothing like that
but it was definitely that feeling where
you know that this is a person that
really knows what they're talking about
that they are very powerful and they
have the network to do what they say
that they can do and that has a
different sort of aura that as a
different sort of poll I suppose it is
magnetic just in a different way so he
recruits you and you decided to go run
with them what happens next so I joined
this company and immediately I'm
introduced to some of the people that I
suppose I would have considered my
mentors in in most situations the
Cambridge analytic oh or the SCL group
strategic communications Laboratories
which was what it was called at the time
the parent company they had a lot of
other people that had spent their life
in human rights work and in you know
humanitarian operations people from the
International Rescue Committee and the
United Nations and diplomats from the
Commonwealth and Wow I thought these
people are amazing I can't wait to work
with them we started working on all of
these different projects that were both
humanitarian some were defense and some
of them were politics in countries that
I had never been to before I didn't know
much about so it was a very steep
learning curve when I first got there
and what do you do what is your role is
it bizdev are you mainly going building
relationships you're not necessarily
doing the data analytics what
in Cambridge analytics right so I had no
data experience before really not much I
mean obviously working on the Obama
campaign I had digital and social media
strategy experience but not data
analytics and data science so my role in
the company was business development so
I would go out and build relationships
with people who could use data analytics
or were approaching us that they wanted
to use data analytics and figure out
what their goals were what capacity they
had you know what they're trying to
achieve and help design a program so
that usually included me helping design
a proposal of how they were gonna use
data how that would help them achieve
their goals and then moving that through
to contract and helping build the team
that would go do that for them so are
you selling are you pitching somebody
else is selling and closing I am usually
well in the very beginning I was working
with Alexander or dr. Alex Taylor who
was the chief data scientist at the time
and they would do the main pitching in
the beginning until I was at the company
for long enough to start pitches on my
own but I took me about six months to
learn enough from every department to
actually be able to go do that by myself
eventually the goal impressive six
months later for you to start pitching
and sitting down with these high-profile
people that's that's the that takes a
lot to be able to how would you at that
time when you're doing this this is a 26
you're 26 when you're doing it yes and
you were sitting with some of the most
powerful people in the world yes and
you're signing Khan you getting them to
agree to do business with you guys and
spend millions of dollars on advertising
yes it's pretty impressive to be able to
do that so you're going you're building
relationships you're bringing them in
they're signing the contracts is it
purely a marketing strategy pitch that
you're talking to them about or is it
were the best of the best were the only
game in town like that you guys almost
have a monopoly in that play or no so in
some respects I the SCL group had so
much global experience in running
political campaigns that that was the
big pitch at
oh look at what we've done all around
the world all of these huge campaigns in
countries with up to hundreds of
millions of people or you know tiny
island nations any size of political
campaign we can figure out a strategy we
can execute and we can win if you give
us enough time and funding and that was
kind of the big play because on the data
analytic side that was very new I joined
the company in 2014 and only in 2013 did
they birth Cambridge analytic which was
to be the the North American the North
American subsidiary of the SEL group
specifically because in the United
States there weren't any data laws or
regulations and therefore the amount of
data that you could purchase and license
to do predictive analytics was unmatched
anywhere else so let's unpack the the
company who is behind it because you see
a lot of names that come behind
Cambridge analytic ah who was there who
was the power the money behind the brand
so for Cambridge analytic Hospice if
eclis it was the Mercer family and Steve
Danon and they came in in 2013 in order
to basically have a separate but like
wholly owned subsidiary of the SCL group
that would just operate in North America
and they were really specifically
concerned with the United States
obviously so Alexander had pitched them
here's all of my political experience
from all around the world here's what my
company can do I want to start a data
analytics company and he had decided
that because Sophie Schmidt the daughter
of Eric Schmidt of Google had interned
for him in 2010 I believe or maybe it
was 2013 sorry I I'll have to double
check in my bug but she had interned for
him and everyday had shown him what
Google Analytics was doing and that
predictive analytics was the future so
he thought as soon as she left I'm gonna
go build my own data analytics company
not just in the eyes of Google but I'm
gonna combine data and politics and
supercharge everything that I'm already
doing now what does facebook come into
play when does when does the
conversation of Facebook come in where
the ability to get five different five
thousand different you know points of
you know tracking of this person is
known for this and that person is known
for this what when does Facebook come
into play right so again that's also in
2013 it was part of the founding
strategy of Cambridge analytical which
was to begin to build one of the largest
databases that anyone had ever seen and
this included harvesting data off of
Facebook which at the time was pretty
easy to do Facebook had started a
program I believe in 2010 where you
could as a developer pay for access to
any of the data for Facebook users
you just had to create an application
you could create something like a game
candy crush farmville or you could
create a quiz the famous one is this is
your digital life which is one of the
first ones that Cambridge made but you
probably also would recognize ones like
what country should you really be living
in or who's your favorite Disney
Princess and so those this has given you
data this has given you information
absolutely I'm sure most people never
read the terms and conditions of those
apps but if you did you would have seen
that it gave the developer of that
application not only your data but the
data of everybody else in your network
which unfortunately is not actually
legally possible not legally possible
it's technically possible but not
legally I cannot consent on behalf of
another able-bodied adult they have to
consent on their own behalf how does
that make it legal though it's not so
how we're able to do it I mean
Facebook's not a small company when
they're doing that Facebook created the
friends API and the friends API allowed
people to do that how much money did
that make them it's hard to estimate
that it's our destiny that I actually
don't have those numbers but originally
they thought this is in order to have a
developer program you know they wave a
carrot stick and
people you get access to all of this
data in order to improve your product
and get more users and whatever it is
and you know you pay us a nominal fee
for that they had at least 40,000
developers participating in this program
so whatever the fees were from 40,000
different companies at the time that was
good enough for Facebook but again they
were still a bit young it was only a
couple years later where they realized
our data that we're collecting off our
users is so incredibly valuable that if
we don't give anyone access to it and
they have to advertise in facebook then
we're gonna make a lot more money and
that's why they closed it off in April
2015 April 2015 and how long did it stay
open about five years I think five years
and a lot of people took advantage of it
absolutely so so is Cambridge analytical
possible to rebuild today not in the not
with the same Facebook data sets
obviously those data sets are still out
there they're all over the world and we
can never get our privacy back because
of it or at least if you had a Facebook
account before April 2015 but you can
build something very similar because the
majority of Cambridge's data was not
from Facebook it was from big data
aggregators like Experian an info group
Magellan axiom l2 two labels and lists
it's a political data company anyone
anywhere in the world whether you're
American or Russian or from anywhere you
can buy that data you can just buy that
data those are that's the lack of
regulation in this country anybody you
can buy that data I saw the number that
the data is a trillion dollar your
industry multi trillion multi truly
absolutely de data is the world's most
valuable asset now it runs all
decision-making and all user experience
and all communications for every
organization for-profit nonprofit
governmental you know ten years ago TEDx
did their convention I think it was in
either C
or Canada this was like maybe 11 years
ago or 10 years ago
and when the speaker's got up and said
the future of business anything you do
it's all about data if you have data you
have value absolutely anybody since then
what are you talking about oil you got
this you got that no data is the future
of everything people that make a lot of
money it's going to be data companies so
Facebook gets fined five billion dollars
what's five billion dollars of Facebook
when they pay five billion Auto fine
it's nothing to them because there's
stock price spiked from all the press
and they made the money back in no time
yeah five billion of Facebook is pretty
much nothing by that this is a point
that I really want to make which is that
it's nothing to Facebook but it's a
really big deal for the Federal Trade
Commission why is that because the the
FTC has never had that type of budget
and they're responsible for protecting
consumers right so now they have five
billion dollars to play with yeah I
think that's a very good thing you know
it might put it it might not be good for
it might not mean anything to Facebook
but it means a lot to the government yes
so what was so so what'd they do with it
now it allows them to go a little bit
deeper with some other companies that
are maybe doing what they're doing I
hope it doesn't just go to
investigations I hope it goes into
investing into technologies that can
protect consumers while government's not
famous for doing good with money so
we'll see what they're gonna delete can
finish a five billion dollars because
you can do some damage with that all
right who is the modern-day Cambridge a
Politico today is there one I wish it
was just one many of them so many of
them is a dominant one not really I
would say a lot of them are still quite
small there's even a lot of them that
came out of Cambridge analytic ah a lot
of my former colleagues sure just
started new political consultancies and
recently I think it was two maybe three
months ago the University of Oxford put
out this really scathing report that
showed companies even worse than
Cambridge analytical popping up all over
the world companies that could be
described as propaganda as a service
which I could say some of that is very
relatable to what I saw at Cambridge and
but some of it is worse they have
disinformation and fake news as a
service they have that as a service yeah
deep this enformation of fake nose
yeah disinformation fake news definitely
saw some dissing formation at Cambridge
analytical but it wasn't really a core
competency but it was used in the Trump
campaign for sure and also a lot of
these companies now have offer bot farms
and making mass amounts of fake accounts
and troll factories and all of these
different things that you know Cambridge
analytical to my knowledge never did at
all Cambridge analytical never did at
all so you guys didn't say this you
didn't say I don't have some fakeness
for two million dollars I'll have some
misinformation for five million dollars
and give me some these Detroit robots to
help me out no a lot of people
unfortunately confused what was coming
out of Russia and what was coming out of
Cambridge analytic oh so that was coming
from them it wasn't coming out at
Cambridge analytical
so so can you can you explain to the
rest of us what is behavioral
micro-targeting traditional micro
targeting and demographic polling of
course so let me start with demographic
pulling so demographic polling will mean
that I'm going to go out and ask
questions of the population and I'm
going to make sure that my polling
addresses the correct amount of men and
women different age groups different
ethnicities different belief structures
different parts of the country or states
that people live in according to the
population so it's weighted properly and
I'm gonna ask opinion questions like do
you like Donald Trump right and that's
all well and good but that doesn't give
you that much information I'll give you
a basic poll okay you know less than 50%
of the country likes Donald Trump right
now okay what do you do with that for
political communications that doesn't
help anything it kind of just
test the water to see where where where
people are at what what is the National
feeling right and so if you're going to
go into what did you ask for the next
level traditional micro-targeting or ba
micro-targeting so the traditional
micro-targeting is going to take all of
these different people and put them into
groups and it's not just going to be you
know alright I'm going to talk to all of
the women I'm going to talk to all of
the youth but sometimes it does look
like that it might just be like okay I'm
going to talk to all of the conservative
women I'm going to talk to all of the
young people who care about the
environment I'm going to talk to all of
the conservative Hispanics in this state
and so it's putting together basic
demographic categories and a little
going a little bit further and then you
will have a handful of different
campaigns that will come out of a
political campaign targeted at those
different types of people an example so
again like we're gonna talk to youth
about the environment okay great
well that might mean that I'm not going
to make any other environmental
campaigns because I've seen that only
youth are active or are talking about
these topics when I've done polling so
we're going to talk just about
environmental initiatives to the youth
because they're going to be the people
that are actually going to get active
they're gonna come out to events they're
going to go vote for me because of my
environmental policy right and so that's
what that will look like now when you go
into behavioral micro-targeting or you
know I was a real micro-targeting this
is when you don't have to pick and
choose your campaigns here and there you
don't just have to choose you know okay
five or ten big topics at different
targeted at different groups of people
you can target every single person in
America if you want to and you're going
to target everybody according to how
they view the world so instead of just
the youth campaign on the environment
I'm going to have a different campaign
towards youth who are open-minded
and extroverted they're going to have a
campaign about how you can get involved
how you can help stop how you can help
stop climate change because they're
gonna go and they're gonna take an
action and they're going to go and
they're gonna share that on social media
and you can find something very specific
for those people to get active that is
about our hope for the future and how
the you know the planet for our children
can be better than it is for us today
now there's gonna be a whole different
group of other youth what that also care
about the environment but they're
introverted and neurotic so you're going
to play instead on their fears about the
environment you're going to show them
those pictures of a polar bear standing
on a tiny piece of ice with melting ice
caps in the background you're going to
show them the giant floating island of
plastic and all of the dead birds and
fish around it you are going to use
fear-based messaging in order to drive
them to action or to care about your
environmental policy and when you're
trying to do something positive in the
world I guess that doesn't sound as bad
when I phrase it on let's save the
environment type of platform but it
starts to get really bad when you talk
about a different topic let's talk about
registering to vote what if I saw that
the open-minded and extroverted people
could be encouraged to go vote but the
neurotic people could really easily be
encouraged to not vote at all because I
could instead make them afraid of
politics I could make them disengage
with government I could make them feel
like their government has never done
anything for them so why should they
care so you could flip and forget like
let's win by not getting the guys to
come out and vote and impose fear that
this may not even happen or there's not
even a chance or don't even worry about
coming out and voting that's on book so
you guys went that deep into it that's
what I was shown in the two-day debrief
that I talk about in my book that I was
given a month
to the Trump campaign all my colleagues
that had worked on the Trump campaign
and the Trump super PAC showed me the
strategies that they used when we were
wondering okay what did you guys do how
did how did you win this this is a crazy
political upset that no one in history
is ever going to forget what did you do
and we thought we'd see some pretty cool
stuff with numbers engagement how did
you get there
what were they clicking on what were the
tools that you used there's a little bit
of that but there was also some really
dark stuff that they showed us and voter
suppression tactics were one of them
they showed us these charts of how they
label different groups of people you
know like I said you know the the
neurotic youth environmentalist or you
know the conservative Hispanic Texan
there's you know these different groups
great but they found groups of people
who were going to vote for Hillary
Clinton
they couldn't ever be convinced to vote
for Donald Trump because the the way
that modeling works in politics is
you're going to show how likely people
are to vote how likely they are to
support certain candidates what issues
are most important to them those are
kind of the the main crux of political
modeling so if you find the group of
people that might vote if they're shown
the right message or they might not if
they're shown the wrong message and
they're on the Hillary Clinton side then
the cheapest way that you can win with
those people is by getting them not to
go to the polls at all because no amount
of money is ever going to get them to
vote for Donald Trump the cheapest ways
to get them to stay home yes that's the
way that these tools are designed how
much did the campaign of folks know that
these were some of the tactics being
used oh they were very aware and there
the target group was called debtor ins
to deter people that for this part yeah
prevent them to coming out
yeah the jury the charts that were used
in the campaign headquarters it was this
big group of people
this chart were called deader ins it's
like an X&Y access you know the Trump
people are over here
Hillary people over here very likely
voters at the top and people who will
never vote in their lives at the bottom
so if you can find people who are in the
middle who may or may not vote and
they're definitely on the Hillary
Clinton side there's only one way you're
gonna use your money so so and then you
guys had also group they called
persuadable what is that a whole
different category no well it's all on
the same chart so the persuadable czar
people that are in between Hillary and
Trump independents libertarians I can go
either way I can go hello react and go
true as swing voters and brand
advertising they're called the switchers
you can really easy get the easily get
them to try a different brand that's the
same thing in politics except pursuit
ability is something that you know it's
very nuanced
to measure everyone's persuadable on
some topics but persuade ability on
presidential candidate is a very
specific type of person right and
finding those people and finding the
persuadable z-- that are very likely to
vote is where the majority of the money
always gets spent now which one of those
groups was the most effective which
would if you were to say you know how
like you you're see we got a marketing
so what's your no more selling product
milk okay and you know it's like the
main thing you got in a now what's the
number one combo I sell us one or you
know McDonald's Big Mac right which one
was the most effective out of all those
different groups from all of the case
studies that I saw and the most
effective were increasing intent to vote
for for Donald Trump with persuadable 's
and decreasing intent to vote for
Hillary decreasing vote to vote for
Hillary so the deterrents weren't
necessarily the biggest ones that help
you out I mean it's a bit of both when
you're winning an election with tens of
thousands of votes in some states every
little bit as something that needs to be
considered now let me ask you what other
clients did you guys have at that time I
know I saw
I think you guys were working with
brexit as well leaving you campaign yes
who else what what other major campaigns
I mean there were campaigns all over the
world
I mean arou Kenyatta and Kenya working
on the last presidential elections in
Mexico um working on I mean even in the
state of Texas for senator Ted Cruz's
primary working in Romania working in
four other parties in the United Kingdom
working for I mean really about 50
different countries over my time there
simultaneously
yeah how much is a team at the time by
the time we reached our peak we were
about a hundred and twenty people full
time and another thirty to fifty
consultants around the world that would
come on for kind of ad-hoc projects
that's not a lot no that's just that's a
small group and you guys were about to
be but I think the CFO Julian said you
guys were about to be a billion dollar
company that's what everyone was aiming
for was that in the talks was that the
conversations behind closed doors are
now really yes Alexander talked about
that every day we're building a billion
dollar company don't you want to be a
part of it so he was a visionary
absolutely now you also said in an
interview that the three-and-a-half
years experience working with him he
didn't have a bad experience
you said you actually enjoyed working
with him like it wasn't like it was you
know something where you said this guy
was my friend he was my mentor at one
point right and then things turned I
thought he was was there a dark side of
working with them or no yes he was very
volatile okay so he'd be the type of
person where out of one side of his
mouth he's saying you know what bar are
we going to tonight after our last
meeting and I the other side of his
mouth he's screaming at you because we
lost a contract to somebody else but he
would also be the type of person that
would say oh I only like yell or get
upset to make a point and then almost
like Jekyll and Hyde he would switch his
personality and then he's like okay
let's go out to dinner
and so that was always kind of jarring
and like an emotional roller coaster and
I always thought okay well you know I've
never worked for you know for profit
company really before maybe this is what
it's like because it's a bit ruthless
its cutthroat you're trying to make
money you know I I had never done that
I'd spent my whole life in academia or
working for nonprofits and advocacy
organizations and charities so I was
like okay well he's building a
billion-dollar company this this must be
what it's like I don't know I think this
is supposed to be normal like working
with somebody like this right yeah and
by the way it's many of them are wired
like that right so many of them are
wired like that you know you had a lot
of people talk about the fact that
behind closed doors Hillary had a little
bit of that herself and had a lot of
people talking about behind closed doors
that Trump has not behind closed doors
for him it's like oh and by the way even
right now when he gives a talk get her
out of here get her out of here see all
that fake news I bet they're not gonna
show the middle finger she put up get
her out of here I mean he just doesn't
even even with the cameras on he's got
no filters exactly which in a way you
know you gotta appreciate that because
you know he's he can't help himself he
is who he can't even help himself on
Twitter you can at least say let me
think about this tweet for an hour
before I send it up now it's going out
so so you get a lot of different clients
yeah David Carroll obviously the guy who
in the documentary the great hack
documentary that's very good question he
said where did you guys get our data how
did they process it who did they share
it with do we have a right to opt out
now your necklace right there which you
are the founder of own your own data
you're the founder of own your own data
is it own your own data that org am I
saying it right so I'm own your data dot
foundation is our new nonprofit but I
actually started the campaign last April
right you know the week after I became a
whistleblower specifically to start
raising public awareness starting to
open up people's minds to the
fact that your date is important yep
your data has contributed to one of the
world's biggest industries and is now
the world's most valuable asset it
surpassed oil and gas in 2017 and its
value yet the entire time you've been
producing data on digital devices which
for some people is their entire lives
you've never had any rights to that data
but how you know a part of that this is
what I'll come back to you and challenge
me on it I actually want to hear your
argument so how many times you hear in
the music industry you know oh my gosh I
sound a cop I didn't know I gave up my
you know rights of this forever to you
how many times have you seen it in
movies you know then these stories well
yeah I was in the contract I never read
I trust you should all read the contract
right or you know yeah I own this thing
myself 51% I thought you wanted 30% no
this I set it up right so how much do
that are we responsible for to just say
oh the new site is called what the
Facebook okay sign me up
I'll go what information do I have to
put in my date of birth where I was born
my relationships complicated go ahead
and put it how much of it is on us to
have the freedom to choose and make the
right decisions on how much of it is on
the creator of the brand of Facebook
well I'm so happy that you asked that
actually because I think it's a bit of a
balance you know
it's important to have informed
consumers and informed citizens so that
we know how to protect ourselves it's
also really imperative that the entire
onus is not on us that companies and
even governments are giving us more
transparency and awareness of what
they're doing and they're not putting us
in a position where if we are not well
educated that we're being taken
advantage of and that we can so easily
be abused so right now we have two
massive problems which is that tech
companies will not make the ethical
decision without being forced to by laws
and regulations that we don't yet have
and decide oh one more time
of course so tech companies will not
make the ethical decision without being
forced to by laws and regulation
that we don't yet have right and so
that's why we're in the position where
Facebook has so much power in companies
like Facebook and on the other hand we
have a population that is incredibly
digitally illiterate we do not
understand what our data rights are how
to protect them we don't understand
basic cybersecurity protocols and how to
keep our data private if we wanted it
that way we don't understand media
literacy you know how to spot
disinformation and fake news
you know kids don't know how to
understand cyberbullying and how to stop
it we don't know how to be ethical to
each other online especially when we're
anonymous these are all things that need
to start being integrated into the
education system because we just have an
undereducated population for our
overexposure to you know our digital
life how much how much of that are we
teaching in high school right now how
much it out are we teaching in junior
high school right now I mean you were
you were 13 14 years old and 13 years
old is what eighth grade seventh grade I
think that's what it is right so how
much it how much of that are is our
educational system right now saying be
careful texting this person messaging
this person if you get a profile like
this let me show you five different
examples or we actually I actually don't
know if we're doing this right now it's
it's not taught in schools but it's just
being it's just starting and that's why
I started to own your data foundation
that's what we actually do we do digital
literacy training for kids in schools
we're starting with middle schools
because we think that's really the first
the first age group like eight to twelve
years old where your parents have
probably given you a phone even if your
parents haven't given you a phone you
might have a family computer and you're
probably using digital devices in school
so you have your own accounts whether it
be social media or you or at least email
accounts you're surfing online for Shore
in order to do at least research
projects but you know a lot of kids have
full exposure they're on their phones
all day every day there are some kids or
if their parents do not stop them they
will actually be on it 24/7
and not having the awareness of all of
the different issues that I just listed
is really debilitating and it's really
harming the the psyche of kids and it's
harming their
chances to be successful fully agree
with you fully agree with that and
there's a lot of things that we don't
teach you enough of I think that's one
of them that we gotta be more involved
talking there was a movie I watched I
think was called connected is it
connected by the guy from Horrible
Bosses who's the guy the guy that the
Jennifer Aniston was no no the other guy
Horrible Bosses Kevin Spacey was his
boss in a movie what's that guy's name
oh I know that was a really funny money
nominal actor right so good but but in
this movie the story is about that his
kid is being bullied online and these
friends servicing in school create a
profile and they say hey you share your
penis with me I'm gonna share the
picture on my grill because I'm gonna
share my privates and they took the
picture of the guy the girl that they
knew he was obsessed with right and he
sends it to him and then the next day
those bullies from school take the
picture and send it to everybody in
school right he goes to school comes
home one day the dad is coming home from
work he goes to his room he's putting
allowed me heavy-metal music and he goes
in he's about to hang himself dad grabs
and puts announces what happened and it
find out what the whole story was that
was a perfect example of what kind of
bullying is gonna be taking place right
if you don't teach your kids one of the
best movies to watch with your kids is
that movie because I think it will show
your kids what is possible anyways I
don't want to digress from it let's go
back to we're talking about would you
would you consider yourself I mean I
know politically I've heard you say
you're burning you were you were for
burning yes not you were not Hillary
camp you were Bernie and you're Democrat
would you still position yourself as
that today or has a change a little bit
I would say the way that I see American
politics is more from an independent
stance especially because I spent my
entire adult life living in the United
Kingdom where actually even the
Democrats in the United States look
quite conservative in the United Kingdom
and in a lot of other countries in
Europe it's taken for expectation taken
for granted that everybody has free
access to health care that if you become
homeless you get a government house that
you can have a weekly or monthly stipend
from the government that will
cover the needs of you and your family
if you fall on hard times so a lot of
the policies in America even on the
Democrat side I find to be actually
shockingly on humanitarian so it's
really hard for long statement you're
making yeah somebody listening to this
could say you could be semi socialist it
can say whatever they want I care about
human rights okay but but economically
you're comfortable more leaning towards
a socialist site if it comes out to
programs to take care of people who just
say you put yourself in that position
absolutely which is why I have always
been a Democrat because I do believe in
social programs I've never voted for a
Republican before although I would
consider it if they had policies that
made sense to me and a Republican that's
been attractive to you anybody that you
say you know what that guy could have
worked uh Marco Rubio really yeah again
it was that crazy moment the first time
that I ever saw him speak in person
where I was just so attracted to his
personality and to some of his policies
and the way that he talks about unifying
people and you know including people
that have usually been left behind that
that makes sense to me and he's a
fantastic speaker oh my gosh yeah maybe
I mean right now I'll take anyone that
even knows how to speak in full
sentences in the White House so it's
fair to say that the gift we had outside
for you of President Donald Trump's
poster signed we had that as a gift for
you we weren't gonna give it to you to
go home with it because yeah I mean
didn't you get like the to America hats
we got two different size for you so we
have a waiting outside food we got mega
candy Magus steak we got everything for
you outside I've seen some really
interesting takes on the Magra hats
recently which say make racism bad again
make racism bat again racism bed again
yeah Mr BA huh unfortunately I think
this president has made people think
that it's acceptable you think so you
fully believe that 100
yeah okay would you position yourself as
a true believer in what in your beliefs
my beliefs yes absolutely like you like
you said earlier if you don't stand for
something you you know you're you
consider yourself as a true believer
yeah I'm back to that okay I had a few
years where I was steered down the wrong
path so the reason why I asked this
question is the following reason because
you know how at first anything we do
were naively in love you know like you
and I are dating we're 13 years old and
I'm the first guy you've kissed you're
the first girl I've kissed I'm like oh
my gosh I love her for the rest of my
life she's my mommy I love her so much
and we're inseparable right puppy love
right yeah and I had that when I was a
kid yeah me too believe me I had that in
Germany at the refugee camp I was
staying at so and then you move on and
you go to a different relationship and a
different relationship and they're
different really and the older you get
doc the tougher it becomes to go
experience what you wants experience
with that puppy love right yeah so for
you you're you're in a family your
grandpa's an mi person 27 years military
you know then from there you go and
you're inspired to work on the Barack
Obama campaign senator you have
breakfast with him with him and Rahm
Emanuel and you're like oh my gosh I
can't believe this person exists and
then you see him when you go back to
school you talk to your professors and
then from there you come out and you
start working on a couple different
campaigns you go to China you're kind of
seeing the human rights that kind of
moves you you come over here you write
your PhD thesis on it then you get
involved with Cambridge analytical then
you're getting involved and then you're
seeing what happened with this campaign
President Trump gets elected he becomes
president then you become a
whistleblower then you step away and
then but you also said some time where
you know even you have to make money so
sometimes to make money you've got to
take some jobs that you don't know what
happens are you are you are you at a
point where you still have that naive
innocence love or wanting to correct and
injustice or have you gone from that to
skeptic to a little bit cynic have you
have you gone to that power politics
gotten you to be a cynic a little bit
right now or now
yet well I think cynicism has its place
it's always good to have a dose of some
cynicism I would say skepticism to make
sure that you are actually questioning
what people are telling you I think I
spent too many years believing people at
face value that what they were telling
me was true and that they actually had
an intention to do something good for
the world when they didn't and so now
I'm a lot more skeptical of what I'm
told I do more due diligence definitely
that I did before before I think about
working with people or thinking that
what they say to the public is actually
what they believe behind closed doors
and you know that's why I think right
now in the presidential field when I
think about you know who represents my
true beliefs some people have some good
things to say but you know I I haven't
earned my support behind anybody
specifically because there's nobody that
really speaks to everything that I'm
talking about I mean the only candidates
that we have that even have Technology
Policy are Elizabeth Warren and Andrew
yang Andrew Yang's fantastic but you
know he would he would make a really
great you know CTO of America but we I
think we really have been shown over the
past few years that we need someone with
a lot of foreign policy experience
someone that can go out and do diplomacy
maybe Elizabeth Warren is one of those
people maybe if she's not but the rest
of the political field hasn't even
thought about data or privacy policy or
Technology regulation and they don't
even talk about it and you know
obviously that's my number one issue at
the moment because I believe it
underpins so many of our other problems
that we have in society that it needs to
be taken care of and it's not being
addressed I wonder who is going to do it
though I wonder who is going to actually
be talking about it because when you
look at I haven't heard Joe Biden talk
about it I have
Sanders talk about it you know yang will
talk about it and people will resonate
with them Elizabeth Warren it's part of
a message Tulsi got to Gabbard I haven't
heard so do you think what do you think
the chances of anybody being able to be
Trump right now the way it's going I
would say right now if it's if it
continues to go as it is right now no
one can beat him no one can beat him not
if it continues to go as it's going
right now what do you mean by that
I think the Democratic side is spending
too much time tearing each other apart
as opposed to actually building a
unified message that can get people to
care about politics again and actually
get people out to the polls I think
right now the DNC is terribly
disorganized and that's unfortunate
now there's another topic of what's
going on right now which is impeachment
so where is that going to go is he going
to be impeached by the Senate we don't
know the articles have not even been
sent over to the Senate I have a strong
feeling after watching the Republican
members of the House of Representatives
making their testimony that it is very
unlikely that the Senate will proceed 12
2/3 yeah I mean so so who voted
president Tulsi Gabbard voted president
to other people voted president right
and a hundred percent Republicans voted
you know against it and a Senate you
already heard what what he said that
he's gonna do it's not even it's gonna
die they want right but do you think
here's a curious question for you since
you've worked in our marketing world and
messaging is critical do you think
sometimes a lot of these candidates are
in the shadow of Nancy Pelosi and the
impeachment campaign that they have that
they're driving where's taking it there
like last night so nobody knew the
debate was taking place last I'm sorry
should we've got a democratic debate
right do you think I also forgot when I
say watch that so do you think do you
think in a strategic way it's actually
hurting the camp because like it's
almost like a father that cannot help
take the shadow away so his spa
his son can you know it's like the demo
DNS he cannot take the attention way to
say listen let let Biden let Bernie let
Warren let these guys get because the
media should be talking about them 24/7
not be talking about impeachment knowing
you're not gonna want two-thirds on
Senate so what are your thoughts on they
think it's kind of a hurting a little
bit of the Democratic candidates well I
think technically it could be but we
can't think of it that way because when
laws are broken and when our
Constitution is violated people need to
be held to account and I'm sorry but I
actually believe that when this
president is no longer immune when he's
no longer in this seat that he will be
indicted for many different crimes do
you think so absolutely how certain are
you pretty sure there's sealed
indictments waiting for him you think so
yes so let me ask you so I mean the same
can be said because for me when we're
going through this here's how I process
it and again I I prefer you challenge me
non-stop the entire time okay so this is
how I process it so when you're when
we're going through Cambridge analytic
and I'm looking at some okay it's very
obvious you know the different kind of
persuadable the deterrence you know the
possible pro-trump the absolute anti you
know Hillary great great strategy I get
it
but somebody could say well Britney I
mean let's not be naive this has been
going on for a long time it just happens
to be that today's tool is this somebody
could say you know there used to be time
we used it by bullying people like
literally bullying people and preventing
some communities are from being able to
vote and no one who to target and
putting the fear into some communities
to not even going to vote by bringing
some power people like in the 1800s and
the 1900s hey making sure people were
fed to vote you know just throw some
food at them they needed sort of poor
areas to win their votes over well then
you know could be we used a mob a little
bit because a mob helps with Kennedy to
help them with election and you know the
mobs involvement with that election that
took place and then well you know what
helped with some of these other guys is
radio whoever was better on radio oh
it's not fair Nixon wasn't good on TV
but Nixon was better on radio but the
reason why JFK won is because you have
kids better on TV and Nixon wasn't good
on TV you were sweating yet in che
he had a four o'clock you know so hey
but that's not fair because Jeff
Kennedy's better-looking you don't need
to vote for a president because it's
better looking at me because Nixon's not
as Hanan handsome as he's and he speaks
as much so or somebody could say well if
you look at media today 99% of media
except for one TV station is on a
liberal side somebody could say
mainstream media's are liberal you can
say MSNBC NBC CBS ABC you know CNN you
can go Time magazine fortune magazine
Money Magazine New York Times LA Times
I'm you can say New York Post try bribe
our DRI Drudge Report right Washington
Times ripe a Washington Post lever
somebody could say well this is great I
don't know why you guys are so upset
because liberals have been doing this
for a very very long time with the media
and the only opposition you have is Fox
so maybe just maybe again I want to hear
your argument on this just maybe you are
getting the taste of your own medicine
why are you upset now because Trump won
because if Hillary would have won would
you have come out and said that she used
some tactics or maybe Trump was in LA or
you know Russia was involved so again I
want to hear your response to that so
I'm just asking at minimum that we obey
the laws that we've already agreed to
uphold voter suppression is illegal
discrimination using racism and sexism
in order to gain power incitement of
violence all of those things are
definitely illegal yet somehow the Trump
campaign and the Trump super PAC were
allowed to use these tactics in order to
get him into the White House and ever
since he's been there he's used some of
the same tactics to stay there that's a
big problem for me and unfortunately
Facebook refuses to enforce these laws
on its platform either even though it is
the world's largest communications
platform I'm not talking about
censorship versus free speech and I hate
that people always bring it to that
because my free speech is not unfettered
my free speech ends when your human
rights begin so I am NOT allowed to
discriminate against you I am NOT
allowed to incite violence upon you
allowed to suppress your vote but yet
somehow I'm allowed to do that on
Facebook or politicians are allowed to
I'm not allowed to because I'm a common
person this is the problem that I'm
talking about I'm with you on that part
I mean are you kidding me absolutely not
but what are your thoughts on mainstream
media because mainstream media I mean
you could say Britain you're a smart
cookie and it's not like you're like but
you're brilliant yourself
I mean mainstream media was 100% team
Hillary mainstream media unfortunately
was 100% team Trump because they covered
him disproportionately and name
recognition everything at the party but
but that's a different story that's
called being dumb that's called being
dumb that's not called being team Trump
that's called the more you talk about
him the more attention you give them
versus the more you talk about so what I
mean by this is the following so let's
just say if you and I break up okay and
and I'm going out there said but you
don't understand she's also this and
she's also she was this she was that she
was this and you know you're kind of
like but look here's what I wanted and
that's not what he wanted I wanted to
have kids he didn't wanna have kids and
so you're talking about why we had a
different I'm talking about how bad of a
person you were
guess who's winning you're winning and
yeah I'm mainstream media right I you
can are like listen we need to build a
wall I hate the wall that's what I want
to do but if you keep on saying wall
wall wall wall wall think about exactly
if no one thought about the wall before
you brought up no I'm not I'm not
sitting here telling you like what I'm
saying to you is I honestly think the
DNC needs to hire a legitimate marketing
firm to help with the language Inc and
if MSM mainstream media needs to
collectively come together and change
their messaging or else the way they're
going right now it's gonna be bad for a
long time because the more you give me
an anti how bad of a person I am
you're constantly building me up I don't
think that's an effective strategy no I
totally agree and something that you'll
I don't know if you'll find it funny or
horrible but after Donald Trump on the
election and we as Cambridge analytic
commercial or going out to pitch
advertising campaigns when we went to go
pick
big media companies they would say you
know we'd get a meeting with CNN for
example and we'd go in and we'd be like
oh well we thought it was gonna be
really hard to get this meeting because
you know you don't like our biggest
client and they'd say ha no we made so
much money off of covering Donald Trump
you're forgiven
don't worry about get out of here yeah
so what does that tell you about their
loyalty is the loyalty to money or is a
loyalty to their beliefs indirectly my
interpretation of what you just said is
they're not true believers no but again
the entire point of a news agency is
that's they're supposed to do their
research and present unbiased facts come
on
you think the point you you you think
they're supposed to keep themselves in
business you think Sean Hannity is going
to be unbiased you think you think
Rachel Maddow is gonna be unbiased never
you you you think a cooper or Watters
world you think these guys are gonna
come on now but their entire business
model is I totally get it and continue
to present what they see is news I did
it it's an interesting who the next
candidates gonna be when I say next
candidate let's just say the next four
years
you know he's re-elected because if it
goes like this the strategy they're
using it's going to be disastrous if it
goes this way and yeah did you see the
other day one of the congressman said
don't buy a house in DC rent because
many of you are gonna lose your jobs
with the way you're going right now
because your community is not going to
vote for you it's it's again United
States of America politicians like if
you and I sit down here for instance you
and I we go have a drink together we go
for a cup of coffee we go have dinner
together we're gonna have differences
but we're probably gonna walk away
saying hey we really enjoyed the
conversation this was phenomenally yeah
total like you know he came up as well
you know it's been I'm like listen in my
company I have 50% Democrats we've got
12,000 agents 50% Democrats 50% of
Republicans okay and obviously when I
said 50% of Republicans we got the ten
fifteen percent of middle that's
independent libertarian and obviously
you got a community I could care less
about politics just don't even bring up
anything with
politics I don't want to talk about but
you and I can have that civil
conversation these guys in DC are having
a hard time having a civil conversation
it is so sad isn't it it's very sad it's
extremely sad to see that yeah as we
said when we started our conversation
today you know unfortunately who loses
when there's arguments in politics it's
the citizens that no doubt about it the
voters are losing I'm from the school of
thought of believing that in every
generation like I believe Trump got
elected because of Obama I think Obama
gave birth to Trump about I think Bush
gave birth to Obama and I think Clinton
gave birth to the pendulum and I think
Carter gave birth to Reagan and I think
you know I mean I can go forward you
know we can go back and forth if you
notice what happens we get sick of
something so you know I don't know I
want this I want that back again you
know what it was better one who was
Democrat Republican like we keep going
back and forth but I think the one thing
that I'd love to see happen which I
haven't yet seen in America during my
time of being here I was a Clinton fan
bill I was a Clinton fan obviously
forget about what he did with Monica but
as somebody who was sit down and do his
stuff I was a fan of his it'd be very
interesting if all of a sudden we get a
synergist that's actually able to bring
people together and now I don't know if
it's gonna happen or not maybe I'm a
little bit too optimistic that it's
possible but you know I've seen these
things happen you know you see families
that are divided that somebody comes in
and brings a whole family together it's
a beautiful thing ain't no very very
interesting to have somebody come in
here let me ask you this question we got
like a few minutes left what what is
life like right now for you as a
whistleblower career-wise
your personal life your comfort your
level of comfort of feeling safe your
fears
what is life of a whistleblower today oh
it's definitely the scariest thing I've
ever done I'm not gonna pretend anything
other than that but it's been something
where I've been so lucky that what I
said
resonated with people people actually
care now
they care about their use of technology
they care about being abused and taken
advantage of by big tech they care about
owning their data and actually having
control over the value that they produce
every day and over their private
information if they want to keep it
private but it should be all of our
choice and so I've been lucky you know I
was given a platform I had the
incredible opportunity to work with the
great hat team and we've now been
shortlisted for an Oscar this week which
is just so incredible and I was so lucky
to work with HarperCollins as well to
write this book targeted and to get the
word out there and now I have millions
of supporters around the world who ask
me every day what can I do how do I
protect myself how do I support the own
your data campaign and these are people
that are calling their legislators these
are people that are going out and
getting active some of these are people
that are working in big advertising
companies that are now working on data
protection policy and working on data
ownership mechanisms for their consumers
where that concept didn't even exist in
their companies before I mean it's it's
really a revolution
I've been again you know lucky and
honored to be a part of it because a lot
of other whistleblowers don't get that I
earlier I think it was before this
interview that we were chatting about
national whistleblower Day they all
started the July cried July 30 yeah and
you know it was many days of different
sessions in order to help whistleblowers
in some of these sessions where you know
is your story a book or how to tell your
story to the media was it therapeutic
and you know I at first it was really
disheartening for me because I saw some
people in in this room who had a really
important story to tell they had managed
to find evidence of corruption in
government agencies or within important
companies and they didn't know how to
talk to the media or they had been
trying for years and no one wanted to
tell their story I'm sitting there with
five million
press you know press pieces about me in
my story and a book deal and a film and
I'm just like wow it's so amazing that
some of these people persist and keep on
going even though people are not
listening and the fact that I was so
lucky that people wanted to listen just
blows my mind and I want to address you
know the safety question that you had
which is that you know no I don't feel
completely safe it's not like I get
threats every day but there are
definitely a lot of powerful people that
would prefer if I stopped doing
interviews like this every day and and
would prefer if I stopped if I stopped
pushing data privacy legislation in
Congress but I'm not going to stop the
threats are not interesting to me so I
think that it's just important to
recognize that becoming a whistleblower
is not easy and it's something that
should be encouraged in order to force
transparency and to weed out corruption
you know one day hopefully
whistleblowers are protected enough that
it's a lot easier for us to stop
corruption before it becomes a really
big problem would you say Julian Assange
is a friend or somebody you admire well
he was someone that I admired for a very
long time I think whatever role that he
had in the hacking of the DNC or not
that's not something that I support
obviously but the work that he did in
the beginning and what he stood for for
full transparency and for holding power
to account is something that I will
always support his dropping of the Iraq
war files to show the crimes against
humanity that were committed or war
crimes that were committed had such an
effect on what I did for the rest of my
life and the way that I viewed the world
in the way that I view my own government
and the way that I questioned things so
I think you know he's someone that is in
a very sad situation right now and it's
specifically because whistleblowing laws
are not strong enough and they need to
be how was
when you met with them because I know
UNM had a meeting together how was that
experience it was so sad to see someone
who has been basically in solitary
confinement for seven years he was
nearly see-through and I hardly got to
have a conversation with him I mean you
could tell he was obviously
psychologically affected by being in
there because it was almost like he was
just talking at me for the whole like 20
minutes that I was there you know
everything that was inside his head
because he doesn't really get that much
human contact so everything he was
thinking about he just rattled off and
he you know it's really sad to see that
especially when when I worked in human
rights working with prisoners of
conscience and working with political
prisoners was something that I
specialized in and you know at the time
I really did kind of see him as a
political prisoner I mean his life is
done I mean what are you gonna do two
married kids public life going out
seeing things movies just a date today I
want to go to a restaurant having dinner
he can never do that for the words of
his life Australia is fighting to get
him back but Australia versus America
doesn't usually Australian time no it's
not it's not it's not one that you're
gonna win too often Hey
what are some of the biggest threats we
have today now obviously you know data
is one and by the way you know what's so
weird is I'm a CEO of a financial forum
and I go to a lot of these conferences
with these big 50 hundred 200
billion-dollar insurance companies and
in the last 18 months
the most common conversation that's been
coming up as cybersecurity I mean it's
just it's we've never seen this much
before
and it's continuously coming up right
now right based on what you see and what
you know and being on the inside on many
of these things what do you see as the
biggest threat we are facing today is it
data cybersecurity is a China is it
Russia is it internal is it companies
the size of Facebook Amazon you know
what what do you see as the biggest
threat to the average person I would say
the biggest threat to the average person
is the fact that there is a complete and
utter lack of data protection and data
protection has a lot of different
parts to it right that is everything
from yes
cybersecurity fending off attacks that
could come from anywhere in the world
from bad actors that is also securing
the value that us as individuals produce
the tracking and traceability of where
data goes who has it where it's held
what it's being used for and actually
having any sort of opt-in or permission
structures for my personal information
to be used by certain people for certain
purposes and the right to actually
monetize my own value for myself as
opposed to being exploited data and the
way that it is used means that anybody
in the world can buy my time my
attention and my privacy it goes to the
highest bidder
and right now because of our lack of
legislation and regulation because of
our lack of technology that can actually
manage and track and trace data in a
reliable way it means that our democracy
is up to the highest bidder
and that's what scares me the most which
is why I do what I do every day
what is my data worth what does the
average person's data worth your data
can be worth whatever you want it to be
depending on who you want to share it
with I really hate that Mark Zuckerberg
tells people it's worth it was $17 a
quarter or something like that you know
what I just had a friend that did a
study with you know a set of diabetes
researchers and pharma companies and
said for somebody that qualifies for a
diabetes study how much do you pay for
that medical data because you know most
medical data comes from young 18 to 35
year old white men in college who go for
extra beer money to medical trials right
and so to find someone that qualifies
for a diabetes study it cost them
$28,000 for six to eight weeks of data
in order to find the people in order to
get people to become part of a study in
order to complete that
for a couple months of medical data
which is probably just blood tests urine
samples they go in a couple times right
so if we are to build a future where we
own our data and where we are actually
able to profit from our own human value
we need to have systems where we can
share our data anonymously and securely
where we have laws and regulations that
allow us to own it as our property and
that okay I'm fine if I produce data
with a farmer company or I produce data
with Facebook they can have part
ownership and I can have part ownership
I wouldn't have produced that data
without them that's fine fractionalize
ownership is cool but we really need to
recognize that we have rights to the
information that we produce in order to
flip the switch and change these
business models from being exploited to
empowering I think it's gonna come soon
though I actually think's gonna come
soon I don't think it's something that's
you know x some idea comes in there's a
little bit of abuse there's and then
there's a lot of abuse then there's
incredible wealth made and then there's
some regulations yes and then you kind
of work it out with the regulators and
the entrepreneurs and they make you work
I actually think based on what you're
saying it's reasonable business like
Facebook myself Kyle paid this much for
your data I'll pay this much for your
data let's partner up on it very
interesting what's the cost of being a
president today here's what I mean by is
there dollar amongst I hear the numbers
saying it costs two billion dollars to
be president today why it costs a
billion and a half to be a president
today can anybody get two billion
dollars behind them and be a president
or do you need a little bit of a
pitchman somebody that's going to be
able to be doing the work what would you
say is the number for someone to become
a president well Donald Trump won the
election with 600 million and not a lot
Hilary spent 1.3 billion what does that
tell you it tells you that the tools are
incredibly important he definitely had a
more sophisticated data strategy that's
for sure but I think if we had laws and
regulations that prevented fake news
disinformation voter suppression races
incitement of violence and he wouldn't
have one because that's how he used to
get where he is today
so someone who is a better pitch man won
and saved himself 700 million dollars or
someone would have better marketing
strategy won and saved himself 700
million dollars someone that was willing
to break any laws in order to win you
think that won that campaign you firmly
believe that absolutely yeah and you
you're saying you don't believe
Hillary's camp at all broke any laws I
don't know I didn't work there got it
country so your time off from your POV
of where you're at so so today you think
the campaign this year it's gonna be
that much money spent as well like that
kind of on your thing you're gonna go
we're gonna go a little higher yeah
thanks very much to David bossy ahead of
Citizens United who now has again put
democracy on an auction block and
whoever wants to pay the most money is
going to be the most powerful mouthpiece
that's the biggest disaster that we've
ever had in politics in America the rest
of the world thinks it's insane that we
allow super PACs to exist where you can
funnel hundreds of millions of dollars
through them it's completely insane you
can obfuscate where that money comes
from you can put complex structures so
you don't know who the donors I actually
are I mean it's disgusting it is
disgusting
you think it's gonna go away though all
the first ever the first ever tabling of
the reversal of it has started to be
discussed this year again by Adam Schiff
thank God for him I think it's such an
important conversation especially
because David bossy was also the head of
the defeat crooked Hillary campaign
which was the make America number one
super PAC that was run by Cambridge
analytic and spent all of their money
targeting neurotic people with
fear-based messaging and disinformation
to get them to not vote for Hillary
Clinton what's what's Alex doing today
is he working today absolutely he is I
know from very many sources that he is
still very active as a political
consultant apparently after the
conservative victory in the United
Kingdom he was seen with the heads of
the levy you brexit campaign chugging
champagne and Mayfair so still active he
might have had something to do with it
he not he might have I mean at this
point you know anybody who knows who he
is he did somebody asked me a question I
posted a question somebody said tell us
about your involvement with fun where
what's your is it fun we're fun were my
saying it properly pH UN yeah I like
that down from negotiation you're not a
part of it I'll join their board yeah I
was really looking forward to working
with a data company that actually wanted
to give their their data back to
consumers and they had designed a
strategy that I was helping them with
where all of the data that they own on
individuals would be put into a wallet
so an app on your phone you would log in
and you would be able to see you would
be able to see all the data that they
had on you how much money they had
earned off of it and then it would be
given back to you so you now own that
you can decide what they were doing that
was the plan and then I found out that
they were working with the Trump
campaign from investigative journalists
not from the executives themselves so I
ceased all negotiations and I'm no
longer involved with them never receive
oh yeah I've never received $1 a stock a
token from those individuals and I will
not pursue that in the few that's good
to know that's very good to know because
I think what it was a tweet by David
Carroll that said you know look at
Britney Kaiser she's back at it again
yeah involved with these guys and help
and I would trump what are the chances
of Zuckerberg record or see if
Zuckerberg or Dorsey ran how much of an
advantage did they have for being a
president huh well that's that's an
interesting one because 2.2 billion
followers essentially yeah
Mark Zuckerberg was from everything that
I heard had
designs on running for president before
the cambridge analytic facebook data
crisis now i don't think he would decide
to pursue that given the current
atmosphere but considering he has the
world's largest communications platform
i think nearly anything that he wanted
to do he could accomplish if he were to
abuse his own tools if he were to Bews
his own tools yes got it if he were to
views his own I mean he lets any
politician anywhere in the world abused
his tools so why wouldn't he let himself
is that I think at this point the light
is so much on he would have to step down
sell majority of his shares etc etc to
say if I want to do it I don't know if
he's gonna be running although I heard
he gave a recommendation to Mayor P to
one of his best marketers at Facebook to
help mayor Pete and apparently it's
working for him he was able to get some
attention there let's do a quick speed
round okay to wrap this up I'll give a
name and tell me the first word that
comes to mind okay this will be fine
this will be fun first word that comes
to mind whatever maybe tell me the first
word that comes to mind okay Linda Tripp
you know she is actually it's gonna say
old school nostalgia yes
missed out okay cool how about Sharon
Watkins and run whistle blow I met her
okay I met her for the first time at the
Congressional thing at hero hero okay
cool
mark felt Nixon scandal he was supposed
to be prepared no that's great I think
Daniel Ellsberg when I think oh yeah of
Watergate absolutely here's a good one
here's a good one here Jeffrey Wigand I
may not be saying it right
Jeffrey white mama he was a former
tobacco company executive that the 60
Minutes the movie the insider would
Russell Crowe oh I never saw that
obviously well let me put it to this for
you something I need to see 100 okay
hundred it's phenomenal I will Julian
Assange sad sad Rachel Maddow
angry okay Trump criminal okay Bernie
activist Biden vice Hillary Clinton
secretary okay
David Carol professor Robert Mahler
that's how so many words come to mind
um integrity okay uh Amy lobbyist for
these big companies as a profession is
what I'm asking so I'm a lobbyist to
your love too but I'm a lobbyist pro
bono for things that I believe in lot of
different story lobbying is important
but it depends what you're lobbying for
joy lobbying has a place so you do
believe that has a place yeah some
lobbyists are very seedy some of them or
not okay Robert Mercer data scientist
Ted Cruz Senator Chris Wiley
whistleblower Steve Bennett populist
Corey Lewandowski used-car salesman
used-car salesman Alexander Knicks
fugitive fugitive Bloomberg last one mmm
candidate candidate
this guy's got fifty four billion
dollars he's got all the money in the
world to be able to make it really work
I think also has quite a media platform
massive media platform are you kidding
me it's a massive media platform it's
gonna be interesting to see if it's
gonna work as a case study I'm just
curious to know how far he can go with
this work you know first of all Britney
thank you for
what I do want to say is guys if you
haven't yet purchased a book we're gonna
put a link below obviously I open it up
with the book we're gonna put a link
below for you to go well buy a copy and
start reading it I highly recommend you
read this type of content because it's
good for you to be in to know especially
today know when data is now
multitrillion-dollar your industry so
you know how to protect yourself your
business and your family Brittany thank
you so much for coming out I had so much
fun with this absolutely yes it's a
pleasure appreciate you
[Music]